is it true that it's possible to have a
farm
that doesn't produce sort of is carbon
neutral
we have been third party verified
to be carbon impact negative so
belcampo's 25
000 acres and the animals here they in
the all of the carbon including from our
shipping on our mail order
is all offset by the amount of grazing
that's happening also that that
encompasses our partner farms we
we buy a number of live animals in from
other partner farms
that's their impacts also incorporating
that i mean first of all that's
incredible
and second of all is that possible to
scale i don't see why
it isn't i mean it's it's complex to
scale
but i mean we're putting people on the
moon and you have a robotic dog
i mean but those are that's more that's
less about scale that's more about
innovation
so like in many ways what belt camp has
done is innovative
at a small scale the question is whether
that innovation could be scaled that's
where i feel like
we in the industry need more help you
know the ai piece the
intelligence the the the thinking about
ways to do things
differently is where we need more
support and i think it's
been a you know a kind of a
swing in the past couple years where
it's
it meets a mess it's terrible so let's
ditch meat
and our opt for these hyper processed
you know
plant-based solutions and
i'm saying there's a way to make meat
this a part of the solution
and it's going to mean eating less of it
it's going to mean paying more for it
it's going to mean that the farming
systems are more complicated it's not
the easiest path
but i think in the long term it's the
better path and it's also better for
human health
you